Ready to beam up, Jim. Stoffe Tisse auf Goldiebühe Hey, hey, ho, das Podcast du vor. Hey Leute, schön, dass ihr da seid. Herzlich willkommen zu dieser Ausgabe. Vielen, vielen Dank an dieses grossartige Intro von Katmo.
Katmo macht die Sommervibes, bringt die an den Start.
Jetzt habe ich Bock auf Sommer.
Oh, schön mit den Jungs und Mädels am See rumhängen, einfach ein bisschen abhängen und Spaß haben.
Ja, erzähl mir, gib mir mehr Informationen, was du mit den Mädels und Jungs am See machst.
Die Wurfscheibe schmeissen, eine wirft die, Bianca springt, kriegt sie, hat sie gerade noch gefangen, wirft zurück. Mehr Sachen, die du beobachtet hast. Oh, dann nochmal die Malteser-Packung wird aufgemacht. Malteser, mhm. Schön kurzen. Greift da jeder rein. Das Trendgetränk, Malteser wird dann gekämmt. Ah, dann gibt es die kleinen Fläschchen, die man so aufreißt oben. Wo man sich was dann macht, was macht man dann? Die trinkt man nicht. Oh, Likarena mit, immer schön. Einfach rein. Ich kann es kaum erwarten, der Sommer steht vor der Tür, wir sind bereit, wir haben die Badehosen im Anschlag, wir können es kaum erwarten, aber ein paar Monate sind es dann doch noch. Ja, also für mich braucht es kein Herbst und auch kein Frühling. Ich verstehe da nicht, warum man das nicht so gemacht hat wie Nordost. Weißt du, dass man, das war so eine, das Gegenteil von dem, was ich sagen will. Ich möchte sagen, warum heißt es nicht Sommerleid zum Beispiel, weil ich finde, Frühling und Herbst, da wird zu sehr suggeriert, dass es eine eigenständige Idee ist, eine eigenständige Stimmung, aber Frühling und Herbst sind einfach nur Übergangszeit zwischen Sommer und Winter, beziehungsweise Winter und Sommer, und deswegen haben die kein Wort verdient, finde ich. Du hast es wie Vormittag, wo du nicht nochmal ein extra Wort hast für Vormittag, sondern es ist halt Vormittag. Du hast vor Sommer, nach Sommer, vor Winter, nach Winter, später, vor, nach Winter. Später, vor, nach Winter. Kurz vor Viertel, vor Sommer. Finde ich gut, finde ich gut. Wende dich da gerne mal an verschiedene Seiten. Wir haben ja letzte Woche habe ich ja eine App-Idee vorgeschlagen. Wie spricht man das Punkt aus? Wie spricht man das Punkt aus? Wie spricht man's? Da waren wir uns unsicher. Wie spricht man's oder wie spricht man es aus? An der Stelle mal eine große Entschuldigung für die dreieinhalbstündige Diskussion. Das gehört hier nicht hin. Das gehört wirklich nicht hin. Und da sind wir uns auch jetzt, also da muss man auch professionell sein. Deswegen große Sorry vom ganzen Team.
Wahrscheinlich haben Sie unsere Patreon-Supporter den Bonus-Content auch anders vorgestellt, als die dreieinhalbstündige Diskussion, die wir rausgeschnitten haben, wo es unangenehm persönlich wurde am Ende. Ja, und dafür möchte ich auch mich entschuldigen. Also ich möchte das H-Wort zurücknehmen. Ja, das möchte ich auch. Ich möchte das Ö-Wort bitte definitiv zurücknehmen. Nee, das hat mich auch beschäftigt. Und tatsächlich haben unsere aufmerksamen Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer uns darauf hingewiesen, dass es das schon gibt, eine Website, wo man sehen kann, wie man Begriffe ausspricht, wenn man nicht weiss, wie man es ausspricht, auch Vornamen, man ist sich nicht sicher, wie man es ausspricht. Und lustigerweise mit dem gleichen Namen, den wir auch vorgeschlagen hatten. Wir hatten ja Wie spricht man es? Punkt aus und vor wo. Genau. Und es ist vor wo. Es ist vor wo. Ihr könnt auf Forwo.com gehen und euch dort jedes Wort aussprechen. Das liegt nahe, der Name Forwo für die Seite, wo man alle Namen aussprechen lassen kann. Und hier kann man sich jedes Wort anklicken? Löffel, Löffel, Löffel. Also man weiß, wie man es ausspricht. Oh, Löffel, wie kann man das aussprechen? Wie kann man hinter dieses Rätsel kommen, wie man das Wort Löffel ausspricht? Keine Ahnung, wie macht man es? Und dann hat sich jemand Nachmittag Zeit genommen und ist eingesprochen. Kennst du eine Seite, wo man herausfinden kann, wie man Sachen ausspricht? Forvo. Forvo. Forvo. Forvo scheint aus dem spanischen Bereich zu kommen. Forvo. Das heißt, ich spreche. Das heißt, ich spreche aus. Sehr schön. Also gute Seite, schaut da mal vorbei, falls ihr irgendwo in einem Meeting seid und irgendein Begriff nicht genau wisst. Am besten gefällt mir. Aber vorne. Tizze. Und das wäre ehrlich gesagt die coolste Aktion aller Zeiten eines Hörers, einer Hörerin gewesen, wenn ihr diese Seite uns nicht nur zuschickt, sondern auch unter Tietze dann einfach so eine Hörernachricht einspricht. Wo ihr nicht Tietze sagt, sondern Hi, liebe Grüße an euch, hierüber werdet ihr stolpern. Das wäre immer eine geile Idee, so eine Schnitzeljagd. Dafür lernt man doch Hacken, sich da reinzuhacken und das einfach die Audiodateien auszutauschen. Ja, ich glaube, man kann es einfach hochladen. Tietze. Ja, ich glaube, man muss schon zertifizierter Sprecher sein. Aber auch nicht viel Lust gehabt, ne? Nee. Titze. Titze. Das war das Wort 380 auf der Liste. Ich kann es aussprechen. Das heißt, falls jetzt mal jemandem gegenüber sitzt und nicht wisst, wie ihr den Namen ausspricht, dann könnt ihr sagen... Lisa. Lisa. Nee, ich heisse Lisa. Lisa Ryder. Was? Lisa Scottley.
Lisa Kudrow.
Kudrow zum Beispiel, weiss man genau, oder?
Aber solange es nicht Lisa Kudrow einspricht, wer ist er, das zu wissen?
Warum soll ich ihm trauen, dass es Lisa Kudrow heisst, mit blaulichem Hintergrund?
Und auch bei Schauspielern, wo man es oft nicht weiss, z.B. die irische Schauspielerin, die einen legendär schweren Namen hat auszusprechen, kann man hier sich einfach anhören. Sierchronen. Das hat nicht geholfen. Die Schauspielerin Sierch, Sierch, Sierch, Sierch? Nee, Sjasch. Aber hier heisst's ... Serschronen. Serschronen. Serschronen. Serschronen. Also könnt ihr alles aus, falls ihr nicht wisst, wie man den ausspricht, gebt das einfach ein Vorwurf haben wir gefunden, vielen Dank an unsere Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, dass die uns erneut eine Idee aus den Händen gerissen haben. Das sind Millionen Dollar, die jetzt auf der Strasse liegen, die wir hätten einfach aufsammeln können, die sind uns runtergefahren aus dem Rucksack, aus dem offenen Rucksack. Und dann kommst du zu Hause an und merkst, mein Rucksack war die ganze Zeit offen, die Geldscheine sind rausgeflogen, wo sind die jetzt, dreh ich nochmal um, fahr ich zurück und sammle alles auf? Nein! Nein, nein. Nö, es kann ja schön Forwo alles haben. Ich gönne denen das, den Erfolg. Ich finde das gut. Ob das auch aus dem Podcast entstanden ist? Ob das so eine Marc-Marin-Idee ist? Das kann ja auch sein.
Das kann sein, ja. Ich glaube das gut. Ob das auch aus dem Podcast entstanden ist? Ob das so eine Marc-Marin-Idee ist? Das kann ja auch sein.
Das kann sein, ja. Ich glaube, die meisten guten Ideen sind in Podcasts entstanden.
Naja, und ohne Scheiß, ich glaube wirklich, dass es einfach ist, die Erklärung auch, man labert die ganze Zeit und lässt erstmal jeden Gedanken zu.
Und das ist ja im Alltag nicht so. Im Alltag sind wir beide ja auch bornierte Arschlöcher, die die ganze Zeit super ernst immer antworten auf alles und dem Protokoll ganz, ganz minutiös folgen. Und ich glaube, in solchen Situationen kommst du nicht auf freie Ideen, du kommst nicht darauf, dass man Names, Names, Names, Names, Names, Names, Names.com, Bandnamen, diese ganz tollen Ideen, diese Millionen-Dollar-Ideen, die hast du ja dann nicht im Alltag. Auf jeden Fall. Ich bin auch, ich glaube auch fest daran, dass wir noch irgendwann eine richtig gute Idee haben werden, weil ich denke mir immer, wenn die Idee richtig gut ist, würden sie Hörer klauen.
Das ist immer so mein Kompass, mein Millionärskompass. Gute Ideen werden in der Regel geklaut. Ich glaube, bei jeder Idee, wo man sagt, boah, hier Edison, die Glühbirne, Kleopatra, die Pyramiden, wenn du immer hinein genau reinguckst, heißt es, nee, da gab es damals einen ägyptischen Podcast, wo irgend so ein Typ gesagt hat, wie wär's denn so ein großer Steinklotz. Und dann hat Kleopatra das gehört, hat das umgesetzt, geklaut. Jede gute Idee wurde geklaut. Das heißt, solange deine Idee nicht geklaut wird, ist sie auch nicht gut. Das heißt, ich hau einfach so lange Ideen raus hier im Podcast, bis jemand die Millionen-Dollar-Idee hat sie klaut. Du verklagst ihn? Ich verklag die Person und ja, dann wird es ein unendlich langer Rechtsstreit, der sehr unangenehm wird für alle Parteien. Wo wir die gesamte... Und über den mache ich dann einen Film. Will ich denn so einen Aaron-Solkin-artigen Courtroom-Drama machen? Ich will eigentlich nur, dass wir mal in einem Gerichtssaal eine Folge das Podcast-Ufo hören. Das ist mein Ziel, da will ich hin. Und wir hören auch die ganze Folge. Mein Anwalt hat sich nicht die Mühe gemacht, die Szene rauszuschneiden. Der Anwalt hat keine Schnittprogramme whatsoever und spielt dann die ganze Folge.
Jetzt ist mein Audition abgestürzt, leider.
Sorry, jetzt müssen wir die ganze Folge hören.
Quicktime, jetzt kann ich nur...
Und dann mit dem Hörer-Intro und alle Geschworenen wippen mit und alle sind gut drauf, mit Cutmo, guter Sommerstyle.
Und dann hören wir die gesamte Folge im Gerichtssaal noch mal. Und doof auch, dass wir uns die ersten 20 Minuten über diese Perücken lustig machen, von Richtern früher. Was machen eigentlich Staatsanwälte? Was ist das für ein Job? Das soll ich nicht, ich kann nichts. Können wir jetzt zu Protokoll nehmen, dass der Angeklagte beschämt auf den Boden schaut und schon mehrfach darum gebeten hat, eine Badezimmerpause zu machen und sich die Schuhe gebunden hat, das siebte Mal mittlerweile, können wir das mit ins Protokoll aufnehmen? Ja, ja, können wir machen. Ist notiert. Ist notiert. Mit so einer langen Zigarette in der Hand. Eine Zigarette mit noch so einem Stiel. Ja, ja, mit einem Stiel. Einfach damit die Zigarette noch länger ist. Die länger ist und man länger ziehen muss, bis man was ankommt. Ist notiert, ist bereits notiert. Auch wenn man diese Figur ist, dieser Stenograf. Ist das ein geiler Job? Graf Steno. Ist bereits notiert, euer Ehren. Er muss auch gar nicht viel machen mit so einer Zigarette, weil er kann von der Lippe aus schon abaschen eigentlich. Er kann sozusagen, eigentlich, ich weiß gar nicht, warum man diesen langen Röhrig noch hat an Zigaretten. Ich auch nicht. Damit man einfach... Quella de Vil hat den doch. Kannst du mal, wie spricht man das aus? Wie schreibt man das? Quella, oder nicht? Quella. Quella de Vil. Ja, vergiss es. Ville. Ja. Ville de Banlieu. Das finde ich gut. Der Stenograf. Der Stenograph. Ja. Der gefällt mir als Figur ganz gut. Also so Sesamstrassen-mäßig aber auch. Wie der Count. Ja. Ist der gleiche Gag auch. Eigentlich sind Gerichte sehr lustig. Gibt es eine gute Gerichtskomedy, mal wirklich so etwas wie A Few Good Men, einfach mal aber saulustig. Aber in der Regel ist es wirklich zum Ablachen. Wirklich herrlich, köstlich. Mit einem feingeistigen, köstlichen Humor. Gibt es sowas? Häufig bekomme ich Konzepte zu Comedy-Serien in die Hand. Weil ich umtriebig bin und die mir angucke. Ich finde das alles spannend. Und es ist häufig genauso. Es ist immer das und dann halt in sehr lustig.
Weil wie willst du Comedy-Konzepte halt verkaufen? Weil die, ich würde behaupten, alle richtig coolen Comedy-Serie, klingen auf dem Papier, wenn man es erstmal trocken beschreibt, erstmal kacke und plakativ und dusselig und irgendwie auch Karikatur auf irgendwie alles überzeichnet. und das ist aber meistens einfach nur, ja das ist halt so wie,
feel good man oder ist einfach so, ist im Gerichtssaal halt in unglaublich lustig, Leute. Aber wie willst du das auch? Du kannst ja das Konzept, entweder du schreibst das Konzept so lustig, aber da sind alle genervt, weil niemand will da schon Gags haben, wenn es darum geht, wie lang die Folgen sind und wie viele Staffeln es gibt. Da willst du das nicht, da willst du keine Gags haben. Das heißt, du musst trocken beschreiben, warum die Serie so unglaublich zum Todlachen ist. Das ist schwierig, richtig schwierig. Aber gibt es da Momente, wo du ablachst, wo du sagst, das ist eine gute Idee? Oder ist alles Crab? Alles Crab. Erstmal ist alles Crab und Goyle, erst mal, und dann später, erst dann im Drehbuch, kannst du ja Hilarius werden. Es hängt ja auch an deiner Fantasie ab, wenn du jetzt eine gute Fantasie hast und dir das wahnsinnig lustig ausmalen kannst. Ich finde jedes Konzept erstmal toll. Ja, wo du sagst einfach, ja, das, ich kann, du, ja, sofort fünf Gags, drei Staffeln, irgendwie tolle Character-Arcs im Kopf. Aber es liegt nicht an dem Konzept, sondern einfach nur daran, dass du genial bist und einfach eine tolle Fantasie hast. Hey, ich hab die beste Fantasie und deswegen finde ich alles erstmal hysterical. Ja. Alles, was ich lese, Sachbuch, Lexikonartikel zu Wort, oh, Mail.
Ja, sorry, ich muss es anmachen für den Forwo.
Fucking.
Entschuldigung, machen wir jetzt keinen Vorwurf. Unprofessional, Vorwurf, Vorwurf. Kann da jemand mal bei Forwo Sachen alles falsch einsprechen?
Ja, einfach falsch.
Wie Luxor und Wunder, was ich ja auch immer noch fantastisch finde.
Ja.
Shoutout.
Ja, finde ich gut. Einfach Löfel.
Löfel.
Lefel. Vorwurf. Lefel. Vorwort. Das ist falsch. Das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Ja, aber auch gerade bei so meines Kompass, auch hier der Vorschlag, lass uns Ost und West streichen, wie Frühling und Herbst. Ich bin gerade in so einer, lass uns die Marie Kondo machen.
Lass mal einfach mal Marie Kondo fürs Leben.
Die grosse Entrümpelung. Wir entrümpeln mal so überflüssige Konstrukte, die noch übergeblieben
sind. Ost und West brauche ich nicht.
Ich brauche Norden und Süden und dann gibt es
Nord-Süd und Süd-Nord.
Und Süd-Nord. Süd-Nord ist offensichtlich Westen
und Nord-Süd ist offensichtlich
Osten. Und dann kannst du ja weitermachen, dann ist es ja Süd-Süd-Nord. Genau. Oder Nord-Süd-Nord. Der Rest gibt es ja dann ganz einfach. Nordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnordnord. Südnord ist offensichtlich Westen und Nord-Süd ist offensichtlich Osten. Und dann kannst du ja weitermachen, dann ist es ja Süd-Süd-Nord. Genau. Oder Nord-Süd-Nord. Der Rest geht ja dann ganz einfach. Nord-Nord-Nord-Nord-Süd. Nord-Nord-Nord-Nord-Nord-Nord-Süd. Und man weiß schon, es ist schon sehr nördlich. Sehr, sehr nördlich. Anhand der N-Wörter, beziehungsweise S-Wörter, kannst du dann erkennen, wie nördlich und wie südlich es ist. Im Grunde musst du dann nur noch N-N-N-N-S, N-N-N-S, N-S-N-S,s, n-s-s, n-s-s, n-s-s, n-s-s, n-s-s, n-s-s oder s-s. Also das gefällt mir sehr gut, diese ganze Vereinfachung. Letztes Mal habe ich ja beschlossen, Städte abzuschaffen, auch der Vereinfachung halber, damit immer die Länder überbleiben. Das wurde tatsächlich übernommen. Das wurde tatsächlich gemacht. Städte wurden tatsächlich nach der Folge komplett aufgelöst. Genau, also es ist eine ganze Städte mehr. Vielen Dank an der Stelle, bitteschön. Also ehrlich gesagt, da musst du hingehen in diese Richtung, um Dinge zu vereinfachen, um dich nicht anzuecken. Du hast recht, mein Leben ist seitdem viel besser, seitdem es keine Städte mehr gibt, keine nervigen Kennzeichen an Autos mehr. Oh nee, das war das Schlimmste. Wenn immer dieses Schild, jetzt sind sie in Köln, du musst nicht mehr pendeln. Du musst nicht mehr pendeln. Ich muss nicht mehr pendeln. Du musst nur noch weit mit der Bahn fahren. Ja, genau. Aber du musst nicht mehr pendeln. Ja, aber ich muss nicht in eine andere Stadt. Nee, nee, du bleibst... Weil ich sage, ja, ich arbeite hier und wohne hier. Ich wohne hier, also du arbeitest auch, wo du wohnst. Genau. Du musst noch manchmal sehr lange mit der Bahn fahren. Genau, ich habe einen langen Arbeitsweg, aber ich muss nicht pendeln. Ich sage ja nicht, dass alles besser ist jetzt. Es hat vieles vereinfacht. Aber ich sag nur, es hat vieles vereinfacht. Nein, es hat vieles vereinfacht. Stadt, Land, Fluss ist jetzt eine Katastrophe. Da kommt man nicht weit. Können wir noch mal Werbung machen für unsere Tour demnächst in Deutschland? Also unsere große Deutschland-Tour. An verschiedenen Tagen treten wir in Deutschland auf. Also wir haben vieles in Nord-Süd-Deutschland, aber auch in Süd-Nord-Deutschland gibt es auch noch Tickets. Und falls ihr Bock habt, kommt nach Nord-Nord-Süd-Nord-Deutschland, da ist auf jeden Fall auch noch viel zu haben. Genau, da könnt ihr mal ein paar Tickets kaufen. Ne, schaut mal auf Podcasts, wenn das Urkommt. Wird eh verschoben. Kann gut sein, dass es verschoben wird, aber also. Ja, wir stecken gar nicht durch. Ich glaube, niemand hat mehr Hoffnung. Niemand hat mehr Hoffnung. Und deswegen ist alles, was klappt, eine positive Überraschung.
Ich habe auch Angst, wir haben so lange keine Ton mehr gespielt, dass ich auch gar nicht mehr weiss, was man da sagt.
Ja, dass wir falsch rumstehen, mit dem Rücken zum Publikum.
Wir gucken einfach komplett nach Süd-Süd und es ist einfach alles...
Es ist kein guter Zeitalter, dass wir im Publikum sitzen und das ganze Publikum auf der Bühne steht, weil wir es irgendwie falsch verstanden haben.
Ja, merke ich.
Ach, scheiße, jetzt wo ich sehe, jetzt ist falsch. Und wir kaufen unser Merch. Und wir atmen ein. Wir kaufen das Merch von den Zuschauern. Die bringen ihr Merch mit und wir kaufen ihnen das ab. Wir sprechen so falsch rum. Hallo zum Blödsinn, Blödsinn, Blödsinn, kann gut sein. Wenn ihr da dabei sein wollt, dann kümmert euch drum, ist nicht unser Problem. Nee, freu mich sehr. Ich hatte eine tolle Woche, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, weil ich habe viele Wails bekommen. Ich auch. Ich habe das Skript gerade bekommen für die Folge, deswegen muss ich da mal ganz kurz einschauen. Achtung und so, so. Also, wir haben ja schon letzte Woche festgestellt, und das freut mich sehr, dass du einfach ein super toller Typ bist, der sich schnell um Probleme kümmert, der einfach sofort, da klopft das Problem an die Tür, du machst sofort die Tür auf, konfrontierst das Problem, löst das Problem und legst dich dann wieder aufs Sofa. So, das ist dein Leben. Bei mir ist es anders. Ich löse Probleme nicht. Und ich habe ein massives Problem haushaltlicher Natur, und zwar mein... Hat es was mit deinem neuen Heizofen zu tun, die Heißluftfritteuse? Nein, dazu kommen wir noch. Dazu kommen wir noch? Gott sei Dank. Wollte ich drauf. Falls ihr es nicht erwarten könnt, skippt auf Minute 42. Nein, mein Waschbecken ist verstopft. Im Bad. Richtig hart verstopft. Ja. Und ich habe das Problem erkannt und ignoriert. Und ich dachte, das wird schon wieder. Und es ist mittlerweile so hart verstopft, dass gar kein Wasser mehr abläuft. Gar nicht. Was dazu führt, dass, also ich habe mir dann wirklich die Frage. Ich habe ein stehendes Gewässer bei dir. Ich habe ein stehendes Gewässer und ich habe mir wirklich die Frage gestellt, wie lange kann ich dieses Problem jetzt mal wirklich ignorieren?
Also jetzt mal wirklich Selbstversuch, weil mittlerweile ist es so, dass so viel Wasser in dem Waschbecken ist, dass um meine Hände zu waschen, muss ich die ganz flach machen und hovercraftmässig über die Wasseroberfläche gehen, sie gerade noch unter den Haaren drücken, so als würde man einem Pferd Essen geben, so ganz, die ganz flache Hand, die flachte Hand. Wenn ich jetzt ein Therapeut wäre, du wirst dich hinsetzen, dann erzählst du mir, wenn du die Woche will, und du sagst, flache Hand, flache Hand, und dann würde ich sagen, sie sind so ein fucking Freak, das ist so fucking weird, ich finde das so weird. Und ich habe, also es kam zu dem Punkt, wo ich mir quasi nicht mehr die Hände waschen konnte, weil also erst dachte ich, ah geil, ich muss es ja nur so hoch schaffen, bis dieser Seitenabfluss erreicht ist. Dann löst sich das Problem. Stellt sich raus. Der kommt ja auch an irgendeinen Punkt. Ich weiß nicht, ob der das bypass das Problem ist. Ich dachte, der hat nochmal ein ganz eigenes Kanalisationssystem, diesen Überlaufstopp-Ding. Auch verstopft. Und auch verstopft. Und dann Schritt zwei, ich habe eine Tasse daneben gestellt. Und immer wenn ich mir die Hände waschen wollte, habe ich mal so ein paar Tassen ins Klo gekippt aus dem Waschbecken, damit ich wieder ein bisschen Spülraum habe, um dann wieder meine Hand so flach wie es geht unter den Haaren zu pressen. Und ab einem gewissen Punkt dachte ich mir, wann geht es nicht mehr? Also geht das jetzt immer so weiter? Das ist wirklich auch ein Problem, was ich auch ab und zu habe und auch eher aufschiebe, weil es echt nervig ist. Aber immer wenn ich das dann behoben habe, freue ich mich wieder darüber, weil es gibt ja, jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob man die benutzen soll eigentlich, aber es gibt ja diese orangenen Flaschen im Supermarkt, die Rohrreiniger. Und es ist ja einfach nur so eine neongrün leuchtende Säure. So eine Simpsons-artige Farbe, also eine Rick and Morty Portalgun-Farbe. Weil du hast völlig recht, darauf lief es dann bei mir auch hinaus. Eines Tages habe ich gesagt, jetzt muss ich mich drum kümmern, habe das alles unten abgeschraubt, das Rohrsystem, dachte, okay, das wird verstopft sein, war nicht verstopft, sondern die Verstopfung muss in der Wand liegen.
Und da denke ich mir, das ist nicht mehr mein Zuständigkeitsbereich. Da kann ich nichts machen.
Hinter dieser Wand, da toben andere Kräfte. Da will ich mich zurückhalten.
Und da denke ich mir auch so, das ist eigentlich auch nicht mehr mein Problem, weil die Verstopfung muss ja irgendwo sein, wo sie für den Nutzer zugänglich ist.
Und wenn sie dann nicht ist, ist das nicht mein Problem. Und dann habe ich genau dasselbe gemacht wie du. Ich habe mir diese Flasche gekauft. Diesen Rohrreiniger, Ätzreiniger, Ätz, alles weg. Wo auch draufsteht, so auf gar keinen Fall atmen. Also wenn sie diese Flasche eröffnen, müssen sie die Luft anhalten. Und ich mag ja diese Warnsymbole immer so gern. Und davon hast du eine Menge da drauf. Da hast du eine Menge drauf. Mein Liebling, ich glaube, wir können auch die Top-8 der Warnsymbole machen. Und auf Top-8 auf jeden Fall der Totenschädel. Ganz straight, giftig, toxisch, du gehst drauf. Ja, also bei mir. Jeder versteht's. Ja, bei mir ist auf Platz 8 das Biohazard-Symbol, weil alle wissen, selbst Leute, die nicht wissen, was es heißt, denken, oh, hier bin ich weg. Das sieht nach Gefahr aus, das ist ein gefährliches Symbol. Dann Platz sieben natürlich das Säure-Ätz-Symbol, wo du so den Arm hast und dann kommt das Tropft oben rauf und du hast so ein richtiges Loch im Arm. Du hast die Hand und du hast so ein Dreieck reingeätzt. Das ist bei mir viel weiter oben. Wo man auch versteht, okay, das ist ernst. Das versteht einfach jeder. Das wird aber dünn bei jeder. Also bei mir ist auf Platz eins
auf jeden Fall das Fische sterben.
Genau, der tote Fisch.
Weil der tote tote Fisch und dieser tote Baum
im Hintergrund, es ist wie so dieses
als Ska bei König der Löwen
die Regierung übernommen hat,
so ein Brachland, wo dann sofort
überraucht ist, überall hat es gebrannt.
Ich wäre gerne da.
Ich hätte gerne diese Storyline gesehen, wie er das hingekriegt hat. Wie lange hat er reagiert? Eine Woche? Du musst auch jetzt mal schaffen. Du musst auch sowas wie Mordor. Wie ist es denn Zustand? Vulkan, Asche, Brachland, wovon leben Orks? Wie ist das passiert? Da leben ja sehr viele Menschen, dass sie alle sagen, wir fassen das Problem nicht an, dass es bei uns schwarzes Brachland ist. Wir sind so zufrieden, wie wir hier leben. Es ist komplett okay, dass wir keine Strassen haben und keine Bäume und kein Wasser. Vor allem, du hast dieses Warnsymbol mit dem toten Fisch auf einer Flasche für ein Mittel, dessen Hauptzweck es ist, es sofort wegzukippen. Wovor warnt mich dieses Symbol? Ich würde verstehen, wenn es irgendwas ist, wo man sagt, es darf nicht in Abfluss, das ist irgendein Reiniger, damit macht man die Fenster sauber, dann bischen man es ab und wirft es in Müll. Aber das ist ein Produkt, das dazu gemacht ist, sobald ich es habe, sofort wegzuschütten. Ich liebe das, das ist das einzige Produkt, das man kaufen muss, um es direkt wegzukippen. Ja, genau. Und währenddessen löst es sogar noch ein Problem. Es ist so kurz in deinem Leben nur. Du hast es kurz und dann ist es wieder weg. Es ist eigentlich das perfekte Produkt. Du kaufst es, kippst es weg und durchs Wegkippen hat es irgendeinen Effekt hoffentlich. Aber der Fisch stirbt halt. Ja, der Fisch stirbt, der Fisch, der in jedem Abfluss wohnt. Aber was ich auch mag, ist, dass es immer eine Benutzung hat. Meistens. Die Flaschen sind nämlich so groß, dass du alles reinkippst. Was für ein fucking Selbstbewusstsein diese Flasche hat, oder?
Ich habe das mal im Supermarkt, da habe ich mal keine Flasche gekauft, weil ich dachte, ich hätte nur was zu Hause davon. Und dann fiel mir ein, ach nee, die sind ja so pragmatisch, dieses ganze System. Ein Problem, eine Lösung. Ja, aber ich merke, so schnell ist es nicht mehr in meinem Besitz und es ist leer und es ist weg. Und jetzt habe ich es über Nacht reingekippt, jetzt bin ich heute Morgen aufgestanden, Rohrweg, Wasserhahn an, 50 tote Quallen wurden nach oben gespült, Fische, alles Brachland, aber der Abfluss ist frei.
Nein, nicht im Ernst.
Ich komme durch und es ist so ein geiles Gefühl.
Wirklich jetzt?
Wie man sich darüber freuen kann über ein funktionierendes Waschbecken, das Simpelste und Normalste, woran sich jeder gewohnt hat, aber wenn man es lange nicht hat und es kommt zurück.
Don't it always seem to go, you don't know what you got till it's gone. It paved paradise and put up a parking lot. So, das glaube ich, da ist was wirklich Wahres dran und deswegen freue ich mich sehr, sehr, dass mein Waschbecken wieder zurück. Glaubst du, du freust dich gerade mehr, als hätte das Problem jetzt zum Beispiel relativ schnell gelöst? Absolut. Du sammelst ja das Leiden, du sammelst den Schmerz und das wird dann schlagartig aufgelöst. Ich möchte nur wissen, wie lang warst du im Minus, Leid, gleich Leid, wie lang warst du im Plus, zu lang, genau, so, es reicht langsam mit diesen Mails, das nervt alle, uns alle hier, sprich für uns alle. Sorry. Okay. Ähm, aus und machst das wieder an oder was? Das verstehe ich immer nicht. Wie kann das denn immer, das habe ich letzte Woche schon, das Mythbusters, ich kann auch nicht mehr mich konzentrieren, weil diese Side-Task aufgeploppt ist, herausfinden, warum es wieder immer anmacht. Warum brauchst du denn überhaupt Ton überhaupt für den Podcast? Weil ich Forvo hören wollte. Forvo. Ich mache es mal wieder an. Geil, ich freu mich schon auf die Mail.
So, wie lange warst du im Minus und wie lange warst du im Plus?
Viel zu lang Wochen, wirklich lächerlich lang.
Ja, aber dann denk ich mir, dann warst du ja wahrscheinlich länger unglücklich als glücklich.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob dieser, dein einer Glücksorgasmus, den du am Ende hat, weil das Becken leer ist, jetzt quasi...
Es ist schon intensiv und vor allem die erste Zeit habe ich mir eingeredet, ich wäre in England.
Weil, so wie ich es verstanden habe, sind ja englische Waschbecken so, dass du zwei Hähne hast, kalt und warm. Und erst mal denkt sich jede Landratte, die auf die Insel kommt, denkt sich, ja, Gertrude, wie soll das denn funktionieren? Muss ich mich entscheiden, kalt, warm, soll ich eine Hand unter warm, eine Hand unter kalt? Die Idee ist, man macht das Becken voller Wasser mit warm und kalt, passt es richtig an und wäscht sich dann mit dem Wasser, das im Becken ist, die Hände. Und genau so habe ich mich auch gefühlt. Ich habe dann schön meine Melone aufgesetzt und irgendwie ein Bild von der Queen an die Wand kehn und dachte, Top of the morning, top of the morning. Good morning,, good morning, my good fella, und ich dachte einfach, ich bin halt, ich bin halt, ich bin in der bathroom, ein mighty little buddy bathroom. Gotta get those sweet, sweet hands clean. Und so habe ich einfach meinen Start. Those sweet little chicken fingers. Those little finger boys gotta keep them clean every day. Clean, my lord. If I touch the queen today, fingers are gonna be squeaky clean. Und so bin ich halt einfach jeden Morgen aufgestanden und dachte mir, ja, ich bin in Great Britain und hab halt dieses Waschbecken. Dieses Becken. Aber lang genug, man kann es halt auch nicht ewig im selben Wasser abwaschen, weil es ist halt, du überträgst den Schmutz nur von einem Tag auf den nächsten. Das ist ein Kredit. Ja, ne, gut. Und irgendwas hat Zahnpasta drinnen und so kleine Kulturen.
Aber auch nicht schlimm. Also Zahnpasta ist jetzt auch nicht die schlimmste.
Naja, es war ja in deinem dreckigen Mund, den du dir gewaschen hast, wenn du mit der Queen sprichst.
Hätte ich wieder geflucht.
Swear like a trooper.
Those bloody Irish!
Aber das ist doch mal irgendwie, das finde ich doch mal ein Urlaubserlebnis, wenn man vielleicht auch nicht so viel Geld hat oder gerade irgendwie die nächste Variante Unwesen treibt. Dann finde ich es mal gut, so Zustände herzustellen bei dir in der Wohnung, um so zu tun und dann einfach Roleplaying. Du bist in England, du warst ja kurz weg, du warst ja abroad. Es gibt ja kein Gut und Schlecht, es ist ja nur immer relativ zur Kultur.
Ja.
In anderen Ländern gibt es ganz andere Arten von wie man schläft oder so, da schläft man auf dem Boden.
Und bei uns denkt man, oh, die Matratze brennt, fuck, ich muss auf dem Boden schlafen.
In anderen Kultursen ist es normal.
Kleiner Tipp, wenn ihr euch fühlen wollt wie in Amerika, by the dawn's early light, what so proudly we hailed, one of our lives last gleaming. Es fiel so hoch, es fiel so hoch.
Dann einfach eine Chlor-Tablette in euer Wasser. Einfach schön so eine, die könnt ihr kaufen. Oh, herrlich chlorisch. Die könnt ihr kaufen so im Baumarkt und so. Star Stripes und Chlor. Star Stripes und Chlorid. Einfach schön rein in so ein Tapwater und dann runter damit und ihr fühlt euch direkt, als wärt ihr in den The Mighty States of America.
Wo du vorhin gesagt hast, dieser Abspülbuster ist das einzige Produkt, das man kauft, um es wegzukippen.
Nicht ganz richtig, habe ich letztendlich darüber nachgedacht, Mülltüten.
Jetzt mal ganz kurz eine Frage da draußen an alle Leute, die in der Mülltütenfirma arbeiten.
Könnt ihr stolz sein auf eure Arbeit, weil ihr stellt
etwas her, was dazu gemacht wurde,
um weggeschmissen zu werden.
100% der Mülltüten werden weggeworfen.
Vielleicht 95%, 5%
auf Festivals, wo man irgendwie ein Regenponcho
improvisiert, aber selbst die werden irgendwann weggeschmissen.
Also du produzierst etwas, damit
es weggeworfen wird.
Nicht jeder hat einen Job, der ihn komplett erfüllt. Wie geht ihr abends nach dem Feierabend nach Hause, wenn ihr in einer Mülltütenfabrik arbeitet, mit dem Wissen, ihr habt den ganzen Tag Müll hergestellt? Oder es ist eine Frage der Perspektive und man schmeißt es nicht weg, sondern man schmeißt darin Dinge weg. Und eigentlich arbeiten sie in einer Industrie, die unsere Städte sauber hält. Aber wirklich viel Wertschätzung kann man einer Mülltüte nicht gegenüber aufbringen, oder? Ich habe noch nie eine Mülltüte in den Müll geworfen. Das und da ist sie den meisten Dingen in meiner Wohnung voraus. Ich bin noch nie auf die Versuchung gekommen, eine Mülltüte zu zerknüllen und in den Müll zu werfen. Doch, ich habe schon Mülltüten weggeschmissen. So, aber jetzt reicht's. Aber jetzt reicht's!
Ich hab eine Mülltüte ...
Als die Therapeut muss sagen, sie sind ein verdammter Freak. Freakish Freak. ... in eine andere Mülltüte geworfen, um sie wegzuwerfen. Und die Mülltüten auch so, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. Wer ist hier, wer ist außen, wer ist innen? Ja. Moment mal. Wer ist in Charge, wer ist in Charge? Hey, hey, hey, hey, wer arbeitetlaub? Wer arbeitet hier? Wer sind Sie? Wer ist on duty hier gerade und die Große so ich arbeite gerade rein rein rein und Graf Steno ist notiert ist notiert das ist doch August Diehl aus Glorious Bastards, oder? Der sagt doch auch irgendwann mal ist notiert ich glaube den Film konnte ich irgendwann glaube, den Film konnte ich irgendwann mal komplett auswenden. Ich glaube, ich auch, der hat diese ganz tollen Tees. Stimmt am Tisch bei Goebbels, ja, sagt er auch irgendwann mit seinem Feuerzeug. Ist notiert. Der hat diese ganz scharfen Tees. Super. Diese scharfen, aber doch weichen Tees. Toll! Toll. Toll. Mir gefällt Inglourious Basterds, ein super Film. Ich glaube, immer in meinen Top-Ten-Empfehlungen, wenn ich Filme empfehle. Ja, ich glaube, ich habe auch die letzten zehn Jahre keinen neuen Film in meine Top-Ten-Liste geschoben. Nein? Ich habe das Gefühl, nee, Black Swan immer noch mit dabei, King's Speech immer noch mit dabei, Inside Out. Das sind halt immer dieselben Filme, so ist auch schon noch eine Weile her, aber ich glaube, es gibt auch Phasen im Leben, wo man mehr aufnahmefähig ist für sein Lieblings X. Also ich glaube, wenn man mal wirklich anguckt, frag mal tausend Menschen, ja, frag mal tausend Menschen, Lieblingsalbum, Lieblingsserie, Lieblingsfilm und du wirst wahrscheinlich feststellen, dass die alle so im selben Alter gesehen wurden. Ja, so 14 bis 17 entschuldig. Ja, ich würde so um die 20 rum sagen, wo man anfängt seinen Geschmack auch als Schild vor sich zu halten. 17 bis 23, ja, ja, ja. Nee, ich glaube eher so noch ein bisschen älter, wo man dann wirklich sich über seinen Geschmack definiert. Weil wenn du acht Jahre alt bist, ob du jetzt die Gummibärchenbande oder Schlümpfe magst. Ich verstehe, was du meinst. Immer kommt man in dieses gefährliche Alter, wo man sich profilieren will, nicht über das, was man mag, sondern das, was man kennt. Und das behauptet, das wäre das, was man mag und so, wobei man auch dann irgendwann merkt, dass man mit seinem Geschmack imponieren kann. Und dann irgendwann hat man aber diesen Geschmack nicht, sondern man eignet sich Dinge an und da guckt man sehr viele Sachen. Und da fällt man, vielleicht fällt da mal zufälligerweise Geschmack und ehrliche Meinung zueinander. Und das sind die Dinge, die man nach wie vor wie ein Schild vor sich erträgt, wie so eine Rüstung, mit der man durchs Welt geht. Richtigerweise erinnere ich mich ganz konkret an eine Szene aus meiner Kindheit, wo ich das zu früh gemacht habe, wo ich mich zu früh profilieren wollte. Da erinnere ich mich noch, da war ich ... Da haben wir Pünktchen und Anton gesehen, toller Film. Klar. Und dann habe ich da eine Klassenkameradin gesehen, war wirklich dritte Klasse oder so, wirklich super früh. Und im Kino habe ich eine Klassenkameradin gesehen und bin dann am nächsten Tag zur Schule gegangen und habe sie getroffen auf dem Weg zur Schule. Mensch, jetzt müssen wir doch erstmal über den Film sprechen, den wir gestern gemeinsam im Kinosaal vier fangen. Genau, und dann halt so diese klassische Kind-Kindfrage, wie fandest du den Film? Und ich war... Wie fandest'n... Wie fand'st'n... Und so war ich... Ich war merkwürdigerweise schon im Full-on-Profilierungs-Smart-Ass-Modus und hab wirklich als, glaube ich, achtjähriges Kind oder so schon gesagt, naja, also die Kameraführung war echt ganz gut und mir hat das ganz gut gefallen. Auch der Schnitt hat mir gefallen und der Score hat sicherlich gut die emotionale Höhe. Absolut lächerlich und sie hat immer nur gefragt, ja, aber wie fandest du ihn denn? Also die wollte einfach nur wissen, gut oder nicht? Und ich einfach, naja gut, also die Schauspieler waren natürlich schon unterschiedlich, ja, und ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, was ich gesagt habe, weil viel Spielraum, glaube ich, dürfte ich nicht gehabt haben mit acht, aber das war, glaube ich, die Zeit, wo ich auch in Poesiealben immer Regisseur geschrieben habe. Deswegen musste ich ja mein Bild aufrechterhalten, dass ich mich richtig gut mit Filmen auskenne und nicht einfach nur sagen kann, der Film hat mir gut gefallen. Aber mir gefällt sie sehr gut, mit den grossen Augen. Ja, aber wie fandest du ihn denn? Ja, genau. Du hast doch gar nicht gesagt, wie du ihn fandest. Ja, genau. Und ich einfach mal nur so, ja klar, die cinematographischen Anleihen, natürlich, da geht viel in die 80er, Nouvelle Vague aus den 50er Jahren, schwarz-wälder, übernommen, der Soundtrack ist natürlich hier und da farblos, fantasielos, was natürlich für so eine kindliche Bildkraft eigentlich unangebracht ist.
Ja, aber gut oder schlecht? Aber wenn es gut oder eher schlecht. Ich habe den Film einmal gesehen in meiner Kindheit und ich konnte mich noch an diese Musik erinnern. Toll, so toll. Du hast letztens nach der Aufnahme Pünchen und Anton gepfiffen und dann habe ich mich noch erinnert, aber ich den auch einmal gesehen habe wirklich früher. Aber das b das brennt sich auch ein dann. Ja, toll, super toll. Aber das stimmt, also man hat irgendwie so zehn Plätze zu vergeben. Und dann guckt man die und danach ist man nicht mehr bereit für neue Highlights. Du willst ja auch keinen raushauen, weil du denkst ja, wenn ich den jetzt raushau, dann habe ich dir die ganze Zeit Bullshit erzählt. Ich habe überall jetzt irgendwie Lola Rent gelobt, Lola lobt, und dann kann ich den ja auch nicht raushauen irgendwann, weil dann würde ich mich ja relativieren, das geht ja auch nicht. So, aber jetzt nochmal die Frage, möchtest du in Zukunft die Probleme, die du hast, möchtest du die früher lösen? Gelobst du da Besserung? Weil irgendwie beobachte ich gerade so dieses, bei diesem Trend des Liegenlassens, dieses Aufschiebens und ich bin mir nicht sicher, was das bedeutet.
Ja, das Problem ist, ich glaube, ich habe zu oft die Erfahrung gemacht, dass sich Probleme alleine lösen. Ich wurde nicht oft genug bestraft für meine Untätigkeit.
Oft ist es so, man bereitet sich nicht vor irgendwie, dann ist eine Hochzeit am Wochenende, du hast den Anzug nicht in die Reinigung gebracht, du hast keinen Hemd, du hast keine Krawatte und denkst dir, fuck, ich sollte mich langsam drum kümmern und dann, ja, Orkanwarnung, Hochzeit abgesagt und du, okay, nichts gelernt, nichts gelernt, ich bleib weiter der, der langsame Schluderer, der ich schon immer war. Also, oder halt irgendwie, wo dann Fahrschule, ja, wo du dann theoretische Prüfung hast, hast dir die Unterlagen nicht angeschaut, hast diese Testbögen nicht gemacht, Prüfung ist in zwei Tagen, du lernst nicht, denkst dir, ja, wie schwer wird das sein, dann Prüfungstag, Orkanwarnung, theoretische Prüfung ist leider abgesagt wegen Wetter und du denkst dir, okay, gut, alles richtig gemacht eigentlich im Grunde. Ja, stimmt schon. Also ein Kumpel hat euch erzählt, dass ein Arbeitskollege von ihm den schlimmsten Brief der Welt bekommen hat, wo dann irgendwie drin stand, ja, wenn sie jetzt nicht sofort die Steuern nachzahlen, dann verfänden wir ihre Konten, wo ich dann auch dachte, das ist, glaube ich, mein größter Albtraum, diese Staatsgewalt, die ja mit so einer unnachgiebigen Art, wo man nichts ausrichten kann, man ist nur ein kleiner Mensch. Dann kommt der Vater Staat an, mit dieser geballten Bürokratikraft, mit seinem Gehstock und diesem langen Mäntel und diesem Hut, mit diesem langen Kragen, der ihm ins Gesicht steht. Und dann kommt er langsam an und mit dieser langsamen, tiefen, bedächtigen Stimme sagt er, wo ist das Geld? Stefan, Tietze, ich hab's nicht. Wo ist das ganze Geld? Und plötzlich hört man, und dem schwarz gekleideten Herrn wedelt seine Kragen ins Gesicht. Orkanwarnung. Langsam aber sicher, die Windstärke wird mehr, die ersten Fensterscheiben scheinen zu klappern. Was ist das für eine Hexerei? Orkanwarnung. Orkanwarnung. Alle Pfändungen sind für diese Woche abgesagt und auf drei Monate oder wie lange auch immer Florin den Will braucht, um das Geld aufzutreiben, verschoben. Gehen Sie zurück in Ihre Häuser, heute wird nicht gepfändet. Oder denkst du dir, ja, leider nicht. Jetzt bist du bei einer Figur, die ich kenne. Das ist der Radiosprecher aus den 30er Jahren.
Nein, das ist diese Figur, die ich kenne aus dieser Serie mit dem Eisbären und dem Vulkan und dieser tollen Musik.
Wie heißt es denn nochmal?
Eisbär und Vulkan?
Es gibt doch diese Serie, diese Kinderserie, die schönste Kinderserie, wo am Ende immer so ein Sonntaggang war und so eine tolle Musik über dem Abspann.
Ich habe jedes Mal geweint und da gibt es so einen Vulkan und da gibt es auch so eine Stimme, die so spricht.
Ducktales.
Nein, ich rede von so einer Kinderserie, die war so schön. Da gab es so weirde Wesen in so einer Vulkaninsel.
Die war so fucking pathetisch auch.
Du meinst Ducktales?
Auf gar keinen Fall mag ich...
Du googelst jetzt nicht Kinderserie Eisbär. Nee, Vulkan. Kinderserie Vulkan. Ja, dann kommt ... Boischi, poischi! Kennst du nicht, Oischi, poischi? Noas Insel. So. Das war ja fantastisch. Das war ja toll. Eine europäische Serie. Handelt von einer im Meer treibenden Insel, die Unterführung der Eisbären. Alles stimmte, das ist eine Vulkaninsel mit Eisbären und Affen und das ist ja wirklich fantastisch. Im Meer treibende Insel? Ja, die mehrtreibende Insel, ja, und die lösen dann Probleme. Im Gegensatz zu den anderen Inseln, die irgendwie, naja, die nicht im Meer treiben, offensichtlich nicht im Meer treiben. Ach so, die schwimmt. Die weiss ich nicht jetzt, ob das einfach, das weiss ich nicht. Du bist nur aufgehängt. Bokat schwimmt einfach so auf dem Meer. So, es reicht, ne? Ist ne Kinderserie. Ist ne Quatschserie. Ja, Paw Patrol ist auch ne Quatschserie. Ist ne Quatschserie. Alles Quatsch. Nein, die lösen Verbrechen, die tun was Gutes. Ja, Hunde, fucking Hunde, kleine Hunde. Auch Hunde, klar, gibt auch Hundeverbrechen. Mit ihrem Kinderanführer, Jesus Christ. Alles Quatsch, Kinder sind immer Quatsch. Lug und Betrug, ist immer Unsinn.
Wir haben übrigens ja auf dem Kinderserien Pui Pui Molka groß gemacht und wieder klein gemacht. Autos sind Meerschweinchen und jetzt wurde ich auch hingewiesen auf eine andere fantastische japanische Serie, nämlich auch ein ähnlich einfaches Konzept, eine ähnlich simple Prämisse, die du natürlich als Serienmacher bewerten kannst. Ist das sinnvoller denn nicht, wird das eine gute Serie und zwar Bananen sind Kätzchen. Super, love it. Bananen sind Kätzchen, mir gefällt die Richtung, in die die asiatische Welt arbeitet gerade mit Serienprämissen, weil das mal High Concept. Ja, das ist mein High Concept. Du hast so wie so eine Banane, die du so aufschälst, und du hast ein kleines Kätzchen drin statt einer Banane. Und die wackeln auch so durch die Gegend. Die haben dann keine Beine, sondern nur diesen Bananenunterleib. Und das ist aber in Ordnung. Also da beschwert sich keiner in der Welt und sagt, Leute, wir haben keine Beine. Sondern die sagen, nö, das ist schon okay. Die sind ja so geboren worden. In dieser Serienwelt funktioniert es ja schon. Und wenn du müde bist, klappst du einfach die Bananenschale hoch und hast da eine kleine Bananenhaus. Isst man denn dann Kätzchen in der Welt auch? Oh, das weiß ich nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Das weiß ich nicht, wie da so ein Bananenkrepp aussieht, ob dann da irgendwie die Katzen geschnippelt werden. Ja, so ein Nutella-Bananenkrepp, das ist dann Katzen-Nutella-Krepp. Ist das der beste Crepe, oder? Nutella-Bananen-Crep, bester Crepe? Ist schon einer der besten Crepes. Ich muss aber sagen, dass ich jetzt, wie schreibe ich meinen Crepe aus? Ich muss sagen, dass ich Nutella, diese Nutella fladen. Warte mal ganz kurz. Ich klicke drauf, oh, wir hören es nicht, weil mein Ton aus ist. Was könnte man da machen? Man könnte ihn jetzt dafür anmachen. Aber ja, vor allem, ich mag einfach dieses geile Tee, dieses Streichtee bei Crepe. Also du hast ja dann, wo du den Teig einmal so rumkreisen lässt mit diesem Holztee. Das ist fantastisch. Ich mag Werkzeug, das nur für eine Sache gedacht ist. Auch zum Beispiel dieser Eiskugelschöpfer, der einfach so krass ist. Und dann kennst du den, wo dann noch so dieses Abstreif-Bogen-Ding hat, wie farthing-gras das ist, das Hightech. Alter, das ist so geil. Ich hatte mal diesen Crepe-Beweger, dieses T-Stück. Und auch eine Platte? Und auch eine Platte, also eine flache Pfanne.
Eine flache Pfanne.
Und dann hatte ich das Teestück und damit
auch wunderbare Krebs gemacht.
Und jetzt neulich wollte ich wieder Krebs machen,
hatte aber dieses Teestück nicht mehr.
Und was habe ich denn dann nochmal benutzt?
Irgendwas Cleveres.
Ich habe Stäbchen genommen
von
ich habe
so japanische Stäbchen und habe die dann dann benutzt, und dann ging es auch ganz gut, ehrlich gesagt. Kann man eigentlich nicht Krepp auch direkt auf der Herdplatte machen? Weil im Grunde hat ja jeder eine heiße Platte zu Hause, eine Herdplatte einfach, oder? Also, warum braucht man eigentlich eine Pfanne? Brauchst du nicht. Warum? Wenn du das nur so nicht ganz heiß machst, dann mach es einfach direkt auf der Herdplatte. Es sei denn, du hast Induktion, ne, wobei auch Induktion. Nee, das geht nicht. Da musst du halt dann nur deine Herdplatte ölen. Warum braucht man überhaupt Pfannen? Kannst du nicht einfach alles direkt auf der Herdplatte machen? Nee, sorry, wenn du Städte abschaffen kannst, kann ich auch mal die Pfanne abschaffen. Haut die Pfannen raus, da ist eh giftige Sachen drin, sondern einfach direkt auf der Herdplatte. Schmeiss die Pfannen in euren Müll, der voll ist mit Mülltüten, weil das braucht man nicht. Schön reisst die Mülltüte auf dem Weg zum Müll, einfach schön reisst, weil ihr einfach sechs Pfannen da drin habt. Wofür braucht man Pfannen und Töpfe? Töpfe verstehe ich. Ja, Töpfe verstehe ich auch. Das kann mir keiner erklären, wo eine Pfanne wirklich heutzutage in unserer modernen globalisierten Gesellschaft... In unserer ach so modernen Küche. Verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Ja genau, heutzutage in unserer ach so fortgeschrittenen Welt das überhaupt noch einen Platz hat. Das klingt wie ein sinnvolles Argument, aber ist es nicht. Aber es klingt so. Argumente haben ja oft so eine Melodie. Und eigentlich muss man nur die imitieren. Ja, und man muss manchmal so Wörter einbauen, dieses ach, man steht über den Dingen, aber eigentlich weiß man nichts. Heutzutage ist auch so ein Wort. Also das ist ja heutzutage ganz anders. Also mittlerweile ist ... Mittlerweile heutzutage ... Mittlerweile in unserer Ach-so-Adjektiv-Welt. Ja, die implizieren, dass man gerade an irgendwas aktuellem Puls der Zeitmässigen dran ist. Aber wahrscheinlich war es seit Tausenden von Jahren so. In unserer Ach-so-schnelllebigen Welt. Vielleicht war es im Mittelalter auch schon schnelllebig, vielleicht hatten die auch Stress. Weißt du doch nicht. Ist schon sehr gut übernommen, weil das sehr langsam war. Alles ist immer gleich und alle denken, jetzt ist gerade besonders schlimm. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein großes Ding, so Zeitreisen, man unterschätzt die Sprachgeschwindigkeit, glaube ich. Früher hat man viel langsamer gesprochen. Meinst du? Ja, viel langsamer. Alles war langsamer. Wie Latein oder was? Man hat mehr Zeit. Pl-u-bi-u-bi-ne, ubi-quam-ne, Ubisoft.
Ubisoft-quam-quam-ne, warte mal, das ist zweiter Dativ im Ubi-num, U-ben-num. Ich verstehe. Fiorentinum si, claro. est en una casa de ne, jetzt ist es italienisch. Si. Das kann sein. Latein hatte weder Ja noch Nein, richtig? Bene. War bene. War bene, aber es hatte kein ja und kein nein. Und keine null. Aber das gefällt mir ja, das ist ja genau der Simplifizierungsdrang, den ich auch gerade verspüre. Du willst nicht null abschaffen. Die null ist eines der grössten zivilisatorischen Errungenschaften, die die Menschheit je gesehen hat. Und du willst wieder zurück in antike Zeiten, wo es keine null gab. Es gibt keine römische null. Wie Wie haben die Fussball gespielt? Startet 1-1
oder was?
Du gehst nie enttäuscht nach Hause.
Du kannst nie sagen, ich habe heute kein Tor gesehen.
Du startest einfach direkt bei 1-1.
Jeder hat direkt ein Tor.
Ja, aber das hat niemand,
da haben die Götter geschossen.
Heißt das, die hatten auch keine Vorstellung von nichts?
Ist auch so ein Produkt
einer Wohlstandsgesellschaft. Gutes Wort. Die hatten immer was und deswegen hatten die nie nichts. Und konnten nie, weißt du, die haben keine Vorstellung von nichts. Aber Countdowns halt auch immer auf die gedachte, also auf die gedachte Eins oder auf, also war. Mehr auf die gesprochene Eins. Auf die gesagte Eins. Ja. Dress. Du hast auch, wenn du irgendwie Spiel spielst, das sind nie Nullpunkte. Es gibt keine Verlierer in dem Sinne. Es gibt immer schon einen. Erst schwierig. Polizei. Eins, eins, Cäsar. Musst du immer improvisieren ein bisschen. Ja, merkwürdige Welt, glaube ich so. Ich glaube, da... Das ist ja eigentlich auch so ein Zeitreisefilm. Man kommt nach altes Rom und sagt, Leute, ich habe euch die Null mitgebracht. Was? Dann erklären wir die Null. Dann erklären wir die Null einem römischen Imperator. Ja, es ist halt eins, dann eins weniger. Ja, aber das braucht man ja nicht. Wie braucht man das denn? Die hatten ja Gründe dafür. Sind die Null nicht darauf gekommen oder haben die die Null aktiv abgelehnt? Das weiß ich nicht. Hallo. Ich Ich bin kurz eingenommen. Hallo. Tut mir leid, diese Zeitreise war wahnsinnig kräftesherrn. Und dieser fucking Jetlag, ey. Hä, wir haben drei und ... Nee, nee, nee. Entschuldigung, Imperator, das muss ich auf Kursung sagen. Ich bin um 17 Uhr nachmittags in diese Zeitmaschine eingestiegen, komm hierher, ein Uhr morgens, krieg kein Auge zu, bin irgendwo im Wald, alles quiekt und quäkt, ich wusste nicht, dass es so laut war in der Zeit, Wald, kein Waldweg, Feldweg, nichts. Ein Uhr morgens kommt direkt nach elf. Ja, okay. Wir haben nichts zwischen. Ich sag nur, dass sie verstehen, wie wir leben. Ich komm ja an, jetlagged, bin jetzt hier im Hofe Caesars und werde jetzt hier ausgequetscht wie ein Hering. Also sorry, aber ja, haben die sich dagegen entschieden oder sind die so nicht aufbekommen? Ich glaube, du kommst nicht drauf. Das ist genauso wie mit so negativen Zahlen oder so. Das ist auch schwierig. Da habe ich auch letztens eine Doku gesehen, von der ich fast nichts mitgenommen habe. Aber da ging es um Mathe. Das weiß ich noch. Okay, mehr. Und dass die irgendwie irgendwas extrapoliert haben und dann haben die da so hart extrapoliert, das kannst du dir nicht vorstellen. Und dann gab es so venezianische Mathematiker, die mussten irgendwie, die konnten sich nicht vorstellen, dass man irgendwas durch Negativ teilt oder so und einer hat dann gesagt, lass uns das mal machen und wir haben gesagt, nee, das kriegst du nicht hin und der hat gesagt, ich mach's mal, ich schreib's mal auf.
Dann hat's geklappt und dann haben alle gesagt, Sacre bleu, du aller, du einer haut die. Dann haben die venezianischen Mathematiker gesagt, Sacre bleu. Und dann ist er aber gestorben und dann hat er aber am Totenbett seinem Schüler gesagt, pass auf, man kann auch durch negative Sachen teilen. Und der war aber nicht so gut, der war ein so mittelmässiger Mathematiker. Er hat auch so gesagt, lass uns nicht in deinem Sterbett über den Job reden, Jesus Christ. Ja, du redest immer nur über deine Arbeit. Immer nur die Arbeit. Ne, lassen wir jetzt hier über... Ne, das ist wirklich bahnbrechend, was ich hier sage. Ja, ich weiß. Ja, gut, so, jetzt machen wir ein Themenwechsel. Statt ist der schlimmste Tod der Welt. Du deinem tölpelhaften Assistenten diktierst du dein geniales Lebenswerk und sagst, ich habe es rausgefunden, trage es in die Welt und der so, hm, was? Achso, ich war gerade noch beim, ich habe ein Tee gemacht gerade. Worüber reden Sie? Und der hat es dann aber nicht ganz gecheckt, hat dann aber die Aufzeichnung gefunden und hat dann da selber Geld damit verdient, weil als Mathematiker konnte man damals richtig gut Geld verdienen. Ist ja heute auch nicht mehr so mittlerweile in unserer ach so wissenschaftsorientierten Welt. Ach so fairen Welt. Ja, und dann am Ende hat aber irgend so ein anderer gesagt, nee, das ist alles, das stimmt nicht.
Ja, war eine coole Doku.
Aber ich glaube, das wäre alles cooler, wenn man das irgendwie mehr so Yu-Gi-Oh-mässig machen würde, dass die halt immer wieder so aufeinandertreffen in der Arena und dann sozusagen sich ihre Thesen gegenseitig um die Ohren hauen und der eine sagt, man. Ich frage mich nur, ob man dann sagen, wenn man in die Vergangenheit reisen kann und sagt, übrigens, was ist mit der Null und sagen dann alle, ah ja, ach Gott, ja klar, oh nein, oh Gott, ich kann es mal sehen, na klar. Oder ist es eher so die Reaktion, die was und dann ist nichts, wie nichts, so was Heissens, sind einfach nur leere Wörter. Ja, kann schon sein. Und dann, das ist halt die Frage, weil, und so stelle ich mir Mathe vor, eher, dass man, wenn man eine neue Idee hat, da muss man erst mal dieses erklären, das abstrakte erklären, und es ist nicht so, dass du sagst, ah, übrigens, es gibt die Euler'sche Zahl. Wenn Euler gesagt hat, hier, ich habe jetzt diese Zahl, das heißt E, und alle sagen, ach ja, na klar, das hat uns noch gefehlt. Unendlich viele Nachkommastellen hat die Eulersche Zahl. Weil sich nichts immer wieder wiederholt, ist sie irrational. Und einen Beweis dafür habe ich euch auch mitgebracht, und die Eulersche Zahl ist ca. 1,718. So irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Ich glaube, das wäre am Hofe Caesars, könnte ich Dorfuchs einfach nachsingen. Und das ist das einzige, was ich mitbringen kann. Eulersche Zahl 1,718 oder 4,718. Unendlich viele Nachkommastellen hat die eulersche Zahl. Und immer, du musst aber von Anfang an anfangen. Und du sagst dem Typen mit der Laute, gib mir mal ein Beat. Puff, puff, puff, puff, puff,
Unendlichs nieder, 8,10. Ich glaube, das einzige, was ich mitbringen könnte, ist die eulische Zahl, Null und, ey, gib mir mal die Laute.
Today is gonna be the day and ... Und alle ...
Ah!
Nehmen die weg.
Und dann würde ich sagen, lauter Drop und würde ich gehen.
Ciao Leute, das war's.
Das war's.
Und dann willst du abhauen in so einem Jetpack. Da würde ich mich auf Marktwert stellen und Star Wars nacherzählen. Und zwar so wie C3PO den Ewoks das nacherzählen. Oh, der Franziker, der Darth Vader. Das ist so. Oh, der Luke Skywalker. Oh, was, wir sind das Millennium mit einem Falken. So cool, ey. Dass der in Star Wars die Star Wars-Geschichte nacherzählt. Und man ist plötzlich der Ewok, weil die Ewoks ja und wir denken, ja, soll ich auch reagieren? Dass der eine Ewok auch so ein Star Wars-Shirt anhat, das fand ich auch geilutes Detail. So ein Han-Shot-First-Shirt. Ein ganz gutes Detail. Ganz merkwürdig irgendwie, wo die damit hinwollten. Plastik ausfarbarem Lichtschwerter, fand ich richtig gut. Fucking Ewoks. Ach ja, war es ein Fehler? Was jetzt? Ewoks? Was? Nein. Hä? Der hat doch auch bis zum Drehtag noch gesagt, alter. I don't know, man, Teddybären. Du hast irgendwie 20 Kleinwüchsige in so Bärenkostümen und denkst dir, Jesus, jetzt wo ich sehe, jetzt wo ich sehe? Aber ist ja so veranlagt, bei Jar Jar Binks hat er auch irgendwann so im Kino gesessen und da gibt es ja diese Aufnahmen, wo er sagt, oh, Jar Jar Binks, I really went far with that Jar Jar-Character. Und diese ganzen Leute da, nein, nein! Nö, das ist gut, das ist gut! Der ist super, wie der da so rumredet und wie der 80 Prozent Screentime hat. Ja. Das ist doch super. Deswegen kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass er sagt so. Und du bist ja kein Star Wars-Fan mehr, ne? Aufgehört. Hast du jetzt eine neue Leidenschaft, also ein neues Franchise? Ich habe meine Jedi-Hobe an den Nagel gehängt. Ja. Ja, neues Franchise ist noch in den Starten. Ritas Welt. Ja, so war. Du bist das Hardcore-Adze-Die-Sketchow. Magda, magda schon, super. Die Dreisten-Drei. Du bist riesen Dreisten-Drei-Fan. Gehst auch auf die Dreisten-Drei-Con? Ich hab mir überlegt, wenn dann einen Film zu nehmen, wo es nur einen Teil von gibt, da muss man weniger darüber wissen. Und wenn ich jetzt irgendwo eingeladen werde als Experte und so, ist die Chance größer, dass ich alles darüber weiß. To Black Swan oder so was. Ja, genau. Dass ich da irgendwie ... Genau. Okay. So was vielleicht. Aber du hast noch nicht entschieden. Du hast jetzt gerade Fankraft übrig. Du hast jetzt deine ganze Fankraft abgezogen von Star Wars, hinter dir gelassen. Ich habe gemerkt, dass ich nach wie vor der gleiche Mensch bin. Ich bin nach wie vor wie mit 18, 19. Ich setze mir eine Idee in den Kopf und will das dann umsetzen und so. Dieses Phasending, dieses etwas rein, das Umsetzen und planen und so. Und jetzt habe ich wieder einmal kurz gedacht so, es hat schon immer Spaß gemacht, so ein Aquarium einzurichten und sowas. Aber das Geile ist, mittlerweile kam ich bei YouTube, habe ich dann so einen Channel entdeckt, wo jemand, weil ich fand die Idee Meerwasser ganz geil, mit mit Korallen und einfach Salzwasser hast. Das sind ja ganz abgefahrene Wesen. Musst du selber salzen, dann mit Jodsalz? Du hast einfach Salz, du machst Salz, kippst du da rein. Einfach klassisches, waardreichener Jodsalz. Tafelsalz. So Knoblauchsalz einfach, du hast kein reines Salz mehr im Hause. Die Fische können auch in Knoblauchsalz. Oder Salzbutter, zur Not auch gesalzene Butter, dann machst du halt ein bisschen, machst du in der Pfanne kurz. Oder auf dem Herd direkt. Naja, und das fand ich einfach geil, weil auch Korallen, das sieht einfach so alien-mäßig aus. Und das fand ich die Vorstellung, fand ich cool. Habe aber einen Channel entdeckt, der von dieser dummen Idee, ich will jetzt ein Meerwasser-Aquarium, bis zum am Ende sterben alle Fische und er schmeißt es weg, hat er komplett alles, die ganzen Phasen, die Höhen und Tiefe, hat er in so einem Videolog mitgenommen bei YouTube und ich fand das total geil.
Dann konnte man sich einfach, man ist mit ihm, er hat auch die Kamera mitgenommen, wie er dann in den Baumarkt, er hat auch in Köln gewohnt, also wie so, ich hätte mir am besten so eine VR-Brille aufsetzen müssen, hätte diesen YouTube-Tannel gucken müssen und er ist in die Kölner Baumärkte gefahren und hat sich Kram gekauft dafür, hat es gebaut, hat Probleme sind aufgekommen, man hat sich selber gefragt, man hat sich selber geärgert, auch wenn Probleme auftauchen. Dann hat er sich aber gelöst und so, am Ende hatte man selber ein Aquarium. Und das fand ich so geil. Das ist gut. Ja, über YouTube kannst du Hobbys indirekt ausleben. Du lebst sie einfach indirekt aus. Du guckst anderen Leuten bei ihrem Hobby zu und musst dir selber nicht den ganzen Scheiß kaufen, viel zu viel Geld und spielst am Ende irgendwie drei teure Fische in den Klo runter. Und der hat ja das coolste Tier, der sich dann gekauft. Er ist dann auch in diese Fischläden gegangen, hat sich dann da Fische gekauft und man selber hat dann so gehofft, dass er die richtigen kauft, die man auch selber kaufen würde. Und er hat sich für das richtige Tier entschieden, was fantastisch ist, was wie ein Pokémon ist, basically. Und zwar ist das die Boxerkrabbe. Das ist eine Krabbe und die sieht einfach aus wie ein Cheerleader, so eine kleine rote Krabbe und die hat so zwei Pömpel in der Hand, wie Cheerleader. Und diese Pömpel sind Anemonen. Das heißt, es ist eine Krabbe, die hat auch ganz normale Zangen vorne, aber dieses Tier hat sie in den Kopf gesetzt, dass sie sich am besten verteidigen kann, wenn sie giftige Anemonen in ihre Krallen nimmt, und hat die so kleine Puschel in der Hand und beide Hände sind ihr Leben lang voll. Ihr Leben lang. Die hat nicht eine Hosentasche, wo man das mal kurz abstecken kann. Es ist wie Polenta. Es ist wie Polenta. Und der Vogel hat sich irgendwann eine Lauchstange geholt und dann läuft es seitdem als Waffe mit rum. Oder dieses Knochen-Pokémon, Knogger. Aber diese Anemonen sind, die leben auch? Echte Anemonen. Und die leben in den Händen von der Krabbe. Ja, die Anemonen leben. Und füttert er die auch? Die sind ja, Anemonen fressen ja, glaube ich, einfach nur so Mikroorganismen im Körper, so Einzeller und so ein Shit. Und die sind trotzdem giftig? Die sind arschgiftig und er hält die einfach fest die ganze Zeit. Und das Problem war dann, dass bei diesem YouTuber, er hat dann so irgendwie Korallen festgeklebt an seinem Riff. Und dann hast du kurz so einen Kleber da drin und so und der zieht dann alles schnell ein in das Riff und die Anemone und dann ist alles gut und dann klebt er zu Korallen fest. Und diese Krabbe ist aber leider da durchgelaufen durch den Kleber, als es noch feucht war. Und wäre kein Problem gewesen für jedes normale Tier, weil jedes normale Tier hat ja Arme, mit denen du dann deine Füsse reinigen kannst. Aber diese Krabbe hatte halt diese Pömpel in der Hand, diese beiden Anemonen und konnte sich das nicht abmachen, weil die das nie wieder
aus der Hand nehmen. Es sei denn, weil das
stand bei Wikipedia, die gehen sehr schlecht mit diesen
Anemonen um,
weil die die immer Leuten ins Gesicht
halten und so. Das heißt, irgendwann sind die dann
auch, sind die dann tot oder
abgenutzt
und dann lassen die die ganz schnell los und greifen sich
ganz schnell eine neue. Aber du hast, es sind einfach Tiere, die ihr Leben lang was in der Hand haben. Und das fand ich, das fand ich faszinierend. Das ist fantastisch. Boxerkrabbe, die sehen so süss aus, sondern eine Krabbe mit fucking Pömpeln, wie ein Chili, da sieht die aus. Ah, das ist auch so geil. Einfach wo du, wahrscheinlich wenn du die siehst, weißt du, es heißt Stress, weil niemand kommt auf deine Party mit zwei giftigen Anemonen in den Händen und will eine gute Zeit haben. Du weisst, jetzt gibt's Stress. Wenn der Typ um die Ecke kommt und direkt zwei giftige Anemonen in der Hand, du weisst einfach, okay, jetzt geht's los. Ich dachte, viel geiler wär's doch, wenn du eine etwas grössere Krabbe bist, und das wär jetzt der Kniff der Natur, dass du zwei Boxerkrabben in die Hand nimmst, die jeweils zwei Anemonen ... Das heißt, du hast so eine Kaskade an Angriffen.
Was war meine Lieblingskrabbe? Eine Krabbe, die eine Krabbe, die Anemonen instrumentalisiert, instrumentalisiert. Oder eigentlich noch eine größere Anemone, die wiederum dann die Boxerkrabbe hat, um sich einfach zu zeigen, wer hier der Chef ist. Wer der fucking Boss ist. Das fand ich faszinierend. Ja, grossartig. Die schläft damit überall, also die zieht den Team überall mit, die lässt die nie los. Und die wird richtig, also die kannst du auch nicht abnehmen, weil die sind so ein Organismus, die leben zusammen. Und der hatte dann Kleber am Fuss und ist überall festgeklebt oder was? Ja, aber er hat es abbekommen, ich weiß nicht wie. Krabben haben ja Gott sei Dank mehr als zwei Beine. Nämlich? Mehr, deutlich mehr. Nämlich? Ich würde fast sagen, mehr als dreimal so viele. Mehr als sechs. Plus, minus, gleich, slash, plus sechs Beine. Ich würde sagen, sechs Beine. Und wie sind die alle gestorben? Weil am Ende waren die alle tot, nehme ich mal an. Naja, Wasserwerte und sowas, ne, ist dann immer ein Problem.
Wasserwerte, ne. Ne, diese Ollen, Nitrat und Nitrit und die Härte, ne, die Härte. Dass die nicht einfach mal so sein können, wie sie sein sollen. Ne, und dann die UV-Lampe und dann macht das. Und das muss ja auch, hängt ja alles zusammen. Es hängt ja, da sagst du jetzt was. Ja, sag ich mal was. Ne, da hängt ja ... Das hängt ja wirklich alles zusammen. Hängt da alles zusammen.
Aber ich bin fasziniert, ob dieses Tieres, finde ich fantastisch. Und da dachte ich mir auch, was können wir Menschen in der Hand halten die ganze Zeit, was unser Leben besser macht. Igel. Um Feinde abzuwehren. Igel-Handschuhe. Mhm. Wir nehmen Igel so einfach als Boxhandschuhe und kämpfen damit gegen andere Igel. Was ein großes Problem ist in unserer modernen, in unserer ach so modernen Welt, dass die Igel...
Die konstanten Igelangriffe, die sich überall in unser Bett verstecken.
Wir lassen es da reinfallen nach einem harten Arbeitstag in unserer kapitalistischen Welt.
In unserer ach so kapitalistischen... Man weiß auch nicht mehr, welchen Punkt wir machen inzwischen.
Wenn wir kurz mal die Ketten des Grossindustrialismus abnehmen und uns in unser wohlverdientes Bett fallen lassen, Stich! Ja, oder so fleischfressende Pflanzen in der Handinnenfläche. Ja, oder halt so zwei Aale. Einfach so ein cooler Zitteraale. Ja, geil, das wäre ein geiler Held, der so Zitteraale in der Hand hat, Aalmann, der dann so eine Elektropeitsche hat, das ist gar keine uncoole Waffe, so eine Elektropeitsche. Ja, finde ich super. Das ist ziemlich geil. Das finde ich richtig cool. Ich glaube, wenn ich ein Aquarium hätte, ich würde wirklich nur Aale nehmen und dann aber auch wirklich so ein grosses Röhrensystem durch meine ganze Wohnung bauen, dass die da so durchaalen können, wenn die wollen, dass die dann so Wege haben, wo die entlangahlen können. Das wäre auch was für dich irgendwie. Ich meine, es würde halt viel Arbeit... Er würde innerhalb von kürzer Zeit kaputt gehen, vor allem ich hätte dann wahrscheinlich einen Leck und dann tropft es raus und ich denke mir, ja, das passt schon, die haben genug Wasser und am nächsten Tag haben die nur noch so halben Stand, ich denke mir, ach ja, gut, es kommt in der Natur auch vor, Flut, Ebbe und so. Und dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich weiterhin mir selber Argumente geben, warum ich das machen muss. Du bist so clever, um immer wieder Argumente zu finden, die dein Leben vermeintlich einfacher machen, was wiederum eine Form von wahrscheinlich Dummheit doch ist am Ende des Tages. Selbstbetrug. Ja, aber wenn der Selbstbetrug dazu führt, dass man sich selber vernichtet, ist es halt... Ich sitze im Gerichtssaal und ich bin sowohl der Anwalt als auch der Angeklagte. Als auch der Kläger. Du hast dich selber in diese Lage gebracht. Ich versuche, mich selber ins Gefängnis zu bringen. Das ist im Grunde ... Oder ich versuche, mich selber auch rauszuboxen. Das ist das Ding. Aber eigentlich müsste ich mal meine gerechte Strafe kriegen. Und wie versuchst du dich selber rauszuboxen? Mit zwei riesigen Anemonen. Oh, herrlich. Grossartig. Ich bin gespannt, aber finde ich ja gut, dass du jetzt auch schon Next Level Stefan bist, dass du die Phasen nicht mehr selber durchmachst, sondern nur noch beäugst und sie andere für dich durchmachen lässt. Ich muss es beobachten, ich muss beobachten, wie gut es mir dabei geht, ob ich denn diese First Hand Erfahrung brauche oder ob ich auch jetzt zufrieden bin, quasi diese Erfahrung mit zweiten Augen.
Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, was
deine nächste Phase wird. Die Wetten laufen ja.
Also es gibt bei einschlägigen
Wettseiten darf ja gewettet werden, was deine
nächste Phase sein wird. Da sind mittlerweile schon
einige, ja.
So eine Spielsucht wäre auch mal geil.
Ja.
So richtig schön, aber dann so Roulette oder so.
Ja. Einfach du am ganzen Tag am Roulette-Tisch und irgendwie so die ersten Wochen ziehst du dir noch einen Anzug an im Casino, aber irgendwann ist nur noch die Jogginghose, Hoodie. Und ein Etardyshirt und so eine Kette. Genau, und irgendwann lungerst du da einfach nur und Rihanna über Plü und du so, komm schon, komm schon die Neuen, komm schon die Neuen, einmal, Papa braucht neue Schuhe, 15ünfzehn! Nein, nein, nein, alles weg!
Roten Augen, wachen Augen.
Ja, finde ich gut, machen wir, da kriegen wir hin.
Ja, macht das mal. Nächste Phase ist incoming,
ich bin mir sicher, da kommt bald was Spannendes.
Freut euch darauf, vielleicht geht's nächste
Woche schon los, bis dahin wünschen wir
euch eine fantastische Woche, haut rein,
viel Spaß, denkt mal drüber nach, ob
ihr vielleicht einem Club beitreten wollt, jeder will mal in einem Club sein, wir haben einen vorbereitet für euch, den Ufo-Club. Könnt ihr auf Patreon beitreten, dann kriegt ihr einen Feed ohne Werbung, falls ihr keinen Bock auf Werbung habt und die Folge immer schon einen Tag früher, könnt ihr mal gerne machen, patreon.com slash das Podcast Ufo, schaut vorbei. Und schaut auch mal auf unserer Website vorbei für unsere Tour, falls es bald wieder losgeht, wir glauben schon.
Es gibt noch ein paar Tourorte mit Tickets, die verfügbar sind.
Viel Spaß auf der Website podcast-ofo.fail.
Haut rein, es geht weiter im Clubhouse, wir haben da immer sehr viel Spaß, falls ihr Bock habt.
Kommt vorbei, ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder und bis dahin heben wir ab, hoch und luft!
It's a voice by production.